Hi everybody.
So first I'd like to thank all of my
viewers and listeners for their
attention and support.
It's been absolutely overwhelming.
I still haven't reconciled myself to it,
but so far so good.
And I hope to continue to produce
content that strikes a chord.
And I would also like to thank my
patrons supporters who have been
extraordinarily generous and helpful and
whose support has enabled many of the
projects that I'm going to discuss
today.
So here's what's been happening and
what's going to happen over the next
couple of months.
The first thing I'd like to announce is
the release today of my new youtube
channel called Jordan B.
Peterson clips.
It will feature clips that are five to
15 minutes long,
some of which will be original and some
of which will be derived from youtube
videos that have already been posted.
It's not obvious what the optimal length
is for a youtube video.
It's new technology.
And so my team and I are experimenting
with videos of different lengths to see
what might be optimal.
So we plan to release two to three
videos a week on that.
And so,
uh,
that's Jordan B.
Peterson clips and thank you to Gillian
Vardy who's going to be my daughter in
law.
She's engaged to my son Julian,
who's also helping on this project.
And also my daughter Mikayla,
who is about to have a baby in about a
week.
So they're all doing the editing and
setting up the channel.
And so thank you very much to them for
the hard work.
And so that's the first announcement.
The second thing I would like to
announce is the release,
sometimes later this month of a new
website that will enable students to
enter their course descriptions of their
university courses and perhaps their
high school courses as well,
along with the professor's name,
the discipline and the university.
And the website has an artificial
intelligence corps that will do a
linguistic analysis of the content of
the course description and rate it as
postmodern,
neo,
Marxist or not.
And so if you're interested in taking
postmodern neo Marxist courses in the
university and undergoing that pathway
of cult like indoctrination,
then you can use the website to do that.
And if you'd like to avoid that and get
yourself a classical education and learn
to speak and write and communicate and
thank and familiarize yourself with the
great works of civilization,
then you can use it to do that.
So we're hoping that that will be an
extraordinarily useful website.
And the overarching goal in part
facilitated by that website is to cut
the enrollment in postmodern Neil
Marxist courses of indoctrination in
university across the Western world by
75% over the next five years.
So that's announcement number two.
Announcement number three is that we're
going to release a psychometrically
valid personality test called the big
five aspects scale,
and it's online form within the next
month.
So you'll be able to go there and do a
five factor analysis of your own
personality that will give you your
ratings for extroversion,
neuroticism,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness,
as well as breaking each of those down
into two aspects.
So for extroversion,
that's assertiveness and enthusiasm.
For neuroticism,
it's withdrawal and volatility.
For agreeableness,
it's compassion and politeness for
openness,
its openness proper,
which is interest in aesthetics and
interest in ideas.
That's intellect.
So openness will break down into
openness and intellect and finally
conscientiousness into industriousness
and orderliness.
And that will enable you to receive a
report on your personality that will
detail how you compare to other people
in terms of a percentile on each of
those five major trait dimensions and
the 10 subsidiary dimensions.
We will also soon after release a
couples or dyad form of the same test so
that once you take the test,
you can have a friend take it or a
sister or a brother or a child or a
parent or an employee for that matter.
And it will give you each a report on
your respective personalities but will
also inform you as to your similarities
and differences and where you were
clashing,
where you won't and what the basis for
your misunderstandings might be and how
to work through them.
And so that's the third announcement.
And then for the fourth announcement,
you may know that we've already created
a set of programs called the self
authoring suite that helps adults right
about their past experiences,
analyze their personalities in written
form.
That's different than getting a
personality report and make a plan for
the future.
The future authoring program has helped
university students increase the
probability of staying in their courses
by about 30% and increased their grade
point averages by about 25%.
We're going to release a high school
version of that at the beginning of
September.
So we're really looking forward to that
and that that will take elements of the
past authoring,
president authoring and future authoring
and make them all accessible to high
school students who will be asked to
look three to six months down the road
in terms of character development and
future plans.
And then finally,
I'm just putting the finishing touches
on my book,
12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos,
which will be published by Penguin
Random House Canada and released January
9th,
2018.
And I'm hoping that that book will
provide further background information
regarding the sorts of things that I've
been discussing in my youtube lectures,
including the biblical series and uh,
provide an introduction to my ideas that
substantially more straightforward and,
and public friendly,
let's say.
Then my previous book,
maps of meaning.
So that's the announcement stream.
So here,
here it all is.
In summary,
I've launched a new youtube channel,
Jordan B.
Peterson clips.
Uh,
there'll be three to five videos a week.
Going up on that.
From five to five minutes long,
we're going to launch a postmodern
Marxists content analyzer and consumer
information site for university students
who wish to avoid being indoctrinated by
the radical leftists who've taken over
the humanities.
And we're hoping that that will help
transform the universities back into
something approximating what they should
be.
We're going to release the big five
aspect scale,
which will enable people to get an
accurate indication of their personality
along the big five dimensions and also
break each of the big five down into two
canonical aspects.
We've developed a high school self
authoring suite that should come out in
September,
that'll help high school students write
about themselves and understand who they
are and start planning for the future.
And I'm putting the finishing touches on
my book,
12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos that's already
available by the way for preorder at
Amazon.
So,
uh,
thank you very much and I hope that you
enjoyed the new channel and also that
you find these programs that we're
developing useful and practical and that
they help you put yourselves together
and lead productive and meaningful and
high quality lives with the least amount
of tragedy and suffering possible.
That would be really good.
So thanks very much.
Bye.